doch wird präsentiert vom neuen toyota
rav 4 4 x 4 und hybrid die ideale
kombination für die schweiz
ich habe heute den präsidenten der
vereinigten bundesversammlung den
vermieter sich auf jede jahren aus dem
boden das ausscheiden werde
gewählt ist mit 125 stimmen mandant
widmer-schlumpf sie mussten quasi wenn
sie zurzeit wenn ich sie eben locker vor
ferner wählerinnen und wähler
volksparteien verräterin man jetzt
zugesagt und zeit wo wir stellen die der
schweiz dann ist es die beste
finanzministerin oder messewand licher
wort wird sagen welche finanzministerium
in den letzten jahrzehnten zu den kosten
eines gesetzes revision nicht kann mich
nicht erinnern dass wir irgendwann
einmal eine gesetzte revision gemacht
haben die keine kosten verursacht hat
die schweiz wieder in die internationale
finanz gemeinschaft geführt wir haben in
all ihren banken team verletzung
us-rechts us-kunden bei umgehung des
amerikanischen steuerrechts behilflich
waren
sie waren als ministerin mit großem
ansehen in europa und darüber hinaus
natürlich linke finanzpolitiker
überwinden ohne große emotionen
jetzt schafft in kurzer zeit bewiesen
wie stark sich dass sie doch sehr
wichtig dass sie ihr kämpferin ist
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein dorf feiert die neu gewählte
bundesrätin eveline widmer schlumpf der
gleiche ort acht jahre später bei
sonntag
die euphorie ist verschwunden
der lokale präsident der widmer schlumpf
partei bdp ist ernüchtert die svp
überholt die bdp die große überraschung
magdalena martullo-blocher überraschend
ich habe dank dass ihr gutes resultat
macht aber dass sie so tödlich gewählt
wird habe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht dank
bdp als erfahrung nach sei das ist eine
partei für die zeit dass ich vorhabe
eigentlich ein wahlverein sie für frau
bundesrätin widmer schlumpf die tochter
von christoph blocher magdalena martullo
blocher ist der star des feiertags dass
ich für mich aus aber das wundert sie
das sie quält wird man muss sie dass sie
natürlich auch sehr bekannt ist dass ich
die größten emery
wenige tage nach dem wahlresultat der
rücktritt ein interview darüber wie sie
dem schweizer fernsehen nicht mehr geben
tauchte das hilflose erfolg verdammt
schlechter abschnitt der foto pa/dpa
paraphiert ein anderer mit die partei
inklusive habe unicef in den darm moment
hat sie darüber entscheide gefällt wo
ihrer praxis sie wird keine mehrheit
mehr im parlament wenn bdp und abstieg
jsvp von hoher ethik wir wieder mitte
links mehrheit tätig wertvoll widmer
schlumpf kamera abbrennt einsprachen
die kobik wo sie auf wahlresultat logan
kennt denn für sie ihren schweren ob ich
sie gar nicht dass ausschlag geben das
resultat ist diese qualen
das ist mit ein grund der der auch zählt
aber es war nicht der grund der mich
dazu veranlasst hat sich bereits vor den
wahlen die diskussion mit meiner familie
geführt habe
rückblende dezember 2007 hinter dem
rücken der svp haben linke und
mitteparteien eine gegenkandidatin zu
bundesrat christoph blocher aufgebaut
[Musik]
vielen dank herr präsident wir laden sie
ein für eine kandidatur zu stimmen
die fähig ist einem mann und einer
rechtsextremen partei die alle macht für
sich will den weg zu versperren
die kandidatin heißt eveline widmer
schlumpf den täter über die andere war
gefrieren könnte ihrem übertreffen
sie hätten ihr vorgänger kurz
kontaktiert und verband gespräche mit
dem herr hämmerle berichtete ich bin
damals parteipräsidentin sie hat mich
über das informiert aber mal etwas nicht
als mögliches szenario
ich meine wir in der bütt früheren büro
gegangen und und erstens wollten
gemeinsam nachrichten klausel die eine
menge typischer macht ihrem signiant
regen bringen die journalistin eilen zum
bahnhof chur
die bündnerin eveline widmer schlumpf
ist auf dem weg nach bern zum
svp-fraktion setzen sagt sie auf die
frage ob sie eine wahl akzeptieren würde
antwortet sie
[Musik]
was weiß eveline widmer schlumpf über
die geheim kandidatur dass sie im zug
zur weniger ware fraktion was mir der
kolonialen nicht glaubt kennt also das
thema ja wir sind gemeinsam hoch wären
klare will mir mit der parteileitung
sprachpakete noch im fraktionssaal
müller mit drei leuten diskutieren warum
sie weiter nationalrat brigitta gadient
und haben so kasseler aus der kommission
möchte er unser werfer das hat grosse
polemik gehe um ein tormann sprache
verlangt und ins immer lauter wurde an
dem spruch nur noch im fraktionssaal den
tatplan es sicher stark wunder hätte
[Musik]
für mich ist ganz klar die bündner frau
widmer-schlumpf ordnung stein heißt das
dass rappaz ihre wo passiert ist rom
sind super gefahren damit sie denn durch
wenn sie quält ist man zwar gewählt ist
mit 125 stimmen man dann
[Applaus]
ich bin mit meiner familie radio
ausgerüstet plenum hat das handy karosse
glauben zu können
fernsehen und radio ist funktional auf
ein paar sekunden schneller xiii und die
haben denn das kriegt und dann im moment
denkt er kann jetzt richtig gehört dass
im krieg welt organisch und in 5 6
sekunden spanischen das auf dem handy
sich taxi um snb glaube kann das
sägewerk für alle überrascht sie und
auch sprachlos
da
die schlagartig bewusst wurde das sei
ganz schwierige situation jetzt durch
die wahl zur kommt das schwierige
entscheidung bevorsteht als berg- und
talfahrt worden
[Musik]
das werde ich in wenigen stunden
offiziell dann erklären ob ich an ihn
oder nicht da nämlich habe jetzt noch
ein paar gespräche zu führen in der
letzten stunde
also sie stellen ihren der messstelle
von core zwischen den messen in züri
umständen ein angesprochen und gefragt
wurde überschlugen und ein bisschen
direkt diene sondern limousine
verfrachtet worden und sind den
richtigen fahrer während der vater mir
sagt was sie jetzt macht und
wahrscheinlich 30 sie dass sie auf
bayern gott und die wahl ablehnt ruf mir
denn mit ihrer das besprochen handy das
mailänder dass ich jetzt gar nicht auf
bayern und st
und wenn den himmel das kann man machen
aber überlegt dass es im moment gut und
während der fahrt ist die idee
entstanden als sie sichern könnte
bedenkt sowie das so andré quält die
bundesrat macht hängt wo sie oft erst zu
mir ob dienten eine leihe gesehen nach
der wahl hat er auch da war oder ist sie
zu mir hoch und einheit ziemlich frage
des sl machen quasi to lose wieso
überrascht es nicht glaubt da aber die
hat einen mitspieler musst du selber
müsse da musst du selber macht lustig
nicht werden sich immer dieselben
spielten sehr korrekt verhalten der
bundestag stimmt absolut nicht
parteistrategie sondern entspannung
[Musik]
diese szene
[Applaus]
wochen später scheint sich die lage
beruhigt zu haben desto blocher stellt
sie seinen chef beamten vor
wie ist ihre kandidatur organisiert
worden
eveline widmer schlumpf hat dies damals
so erklärt ich habe gehört aber einfach
so nebenbei dass man wolle versuchen
eine kandidatur aufzubauen aber ohne
dass mein name wirklich genannt wurde
ich habe dann das so zur kenntnis
genommen und habe das als politisches
spiel wie das hin und wieder eben in der
politik abläuft habe ich mir das auch so
vorgestellt
ich habe dann am dienstagabend also vor
gesten abend eine sms erhalten
das stehe zur diskussion ob es der mein
name ist hase oder ein anderes immer
noch nicht aber das steht zur diskussion
und man wolle von mir auch keine antwort
also man erwarte keine antworten keine
stellungnahme das sei rein zu meiner
information
damit ich da nicht irgendwie völlig
überrascht wären am mittwochmorgen mein
name genannt wurde
doch schon bald kommen zweifel an dieser
version auf wusste eveline widmer
schlumpf tatsächlich nicht mehr
bereitwillig geben mir damals der cvp
parteipräsident christophe darbellay und
die sp fraktionspräsidentin ursula wyss
auskunft mit dem nationalrat andrea
hämmerle persona wo geografisch nach der
frau widmer-schlumpf trennen ist sehr
persönlich gut kennt und die möglichkeit
ihrer früheren zeitpunkt überhaupt eine
möglichkeit wurden in der gleichen
richtung eigentlich am vorabend vor der
wahl 14 12 12h svp namen nach die polit
damit nicht ganze druck sich fokussiert
hat und frau widmer schlumpf am 6 märz
2008 wird mein film die abwahl
ausgestrahlt nach dem ok mir als treffer
karin meyer fällt mit dem neugewählten
parteipräsident vor der svp schweiz mit
dem toni brunner und madrid nur darüber
diskutiert wie wieder gibt's lösung für
unsere bundesrätin gibt sich für partei
und will die delegiertenversammlung
session denn der film eigentlich nie
keine lorca und sind dennoch der
versammlung zu der veranstaltungsreihe
und hätten gute verhindert werde hinter
gemeinsam bei mir die jagd und ja ich
muss sagen ich bin der allierten setzt
sie überrascht wie sie darstellungen
übrigen parlamentarier schlagartig
bewusst dass der dokumentarfilm doch
große auswirkung wird hofer offene frage
in der umstellt und vor allem auf
glaubwürdigkeit von bundesrätin in frage
stellen
[Musik]
als revassist enorm empört sie mir ein
ursprünglich nur der herr schmid und
frau widmer-schlumpf fraktion
ausschlossen
denn ich darf sie also die müll
loszuwerden
verständlich dass unterhalt zu wollen
muss
schwierig war
wir sind einfach da er noch dazu das
heißt man muss aber so wie sie zur zeit
in der der weg bis zum bauantrag bis zum
weg auch wenn das nötig ist den jüngeren
ereignis zum wegner nennt ausstoß
vorsieht das thema absolut klasse
[Musik]
die svp schweiz realisiert hat dass sie
nicht kann als einzelmitglied schlösser
sie mir den als partei aufgefordert
worden die user reihen ausschließen
verdienen die regierungsrätin wo sehr
viel gemacht hat für parteien wo
hervorragende arbeit geleistet hätte mir
natürlich nicht mehr los ist hat man das
abgelehnt um führung von der
kantonalpartei seite des rheines ihn
hört das machen sie nicht die ganze
partei beschlüsse und teils schwere
operation sie haben sich ja vorstellen
und die kantonalpartei ausschließen
das braucht also alles und hinterher und
nicht zerstört das ist so ruhig dass
hinter partei auf einer völlig frei im
juni 2008 nach dem ausschluss gründet
das umfeld von eveline widmer schlumpf
eine neue partei juni und wenn ich als
hersteller mini typische die bänder
sektion gründet wort sehr schnell unter
dem falschen namen
es hat alles relativ schnell vergangen
seit wir heißen bürgerliche partei
schweiz und der nagel herrscht im
nachhinein von reni sprach festgestellt
dass es so weitergeht dann ist auch mit
einer findungskommission ans werk
gegangen unter dem schlussendlich der
name ddp eigentlich vorschlag ab
das neue problem
dies ermöglicht eine bündelung der den
menschen dort
kurz darauf wird sie mitglied der neuen
partei und kurze zeit später schweizerin
des jahres
danke für all die ideen ganz gerührt
ja ich bin mir bewusst dafür dass in dem
land rover lügt nicht nur die der
meinung sind dass man auch harte
politische auseinandersetzung mit kultur
mit respekt mit toleranz regel kann
es ist die zeit in der im bundeshaus
alarmstimmung herrscht die welt taumelt
in die finanzkrise
die grossbank ubs ist am rande des
abgrunds sie bittet um staatliche
rettung der damalige finanzminister hans
rudolf merz bricht mit einem herzinfarkt
zusammen eveline widmer schlumpf
übernimmt verrät nichts plan ist schon
vor ort lager wo sie habe kurzfristig
einspringen
iris verdienen das zweifellos ist die
ganze problematik oft gebrauchte
innerhalb vom boden des wortes hätte die
untersuchung von der gpk feststellte
dass er monatelang die situation für
klein geredet hat die nächsten zwei tage
würde ich sagen
sie hatte fast jack tisch das dossier
fast allein zu vorzubereiten
das war ihr habt fließt und dann habe
ich mit ihr gesprochen und wir haben
gesagt wir sollen wir noch weiter weil
es gibt viel zu koordinieren im
bundesrat und aushärten der bundesrat
mit der nationalbank
ich glaube man muss den ausstand sei es
hat nur zwei gute leute im hintergrund
habe das hat das team gemacht sehr gut
aber es wird sich aber unser team und
hat dann dem team den autoren das hat
sie sehr sehr kompetent damit ein großer
verantwortlich bei musik macht die sich
beschleunigende entwicklung auf den
finanzmärkten hat er den bundesrat
zeitdaten seit wochen auch mit der sorge
erfüllt wir haben das mit sorge
beobachtet und wird haben sie haben das
gehört zusammen mit rebecca zusammen mit
hessen die auch massnahmen geprüft
ich bin überzeugt dass ohne sie wäre es
sehr schwierig die über jahre auf die
bühne zu bringen ja nun mit erfolg zu
schließen
eveline widmer schlumpf hat dadurch
relativ großen vorteil dass das
einigermaßen in göteborg eine
abgewickelt werden und dass man druck
hat die fragen schnitt schlechter als
finanzminister in russland hat das sind
jetzt alle auch ich da nein ich sehe die
bank muss jetzt rettet wertende so
medical otris mit dieser niederlage will
mini muss land zeichen gibt die schweiz
lässt die grossbanken fallen also
ständig das gut gemacht und das hat er
gut gemacht also alles ich ja im fall
schuldig machten sie reich finanzkrise
bewältigt der schweizer aber nicht
schweiz als einziges land oder stadt
kein geld verloren
das ist irre und dem team war habe ich
zwei tagen aus dem richtigen haben liegt
die richtige es auch problematisch
angegangen hat und jetzt automatisch
sehe ich wenn es muss oder bei mehring
deutschland weil sie so bald ich
reagiert und schoss anderen zu ihrer
höheren schaden 3
zahlen
[Musik]
die welt ist mit 131 stimmen
backszat hatte evelyn widmer schlumpf
[Applaus]
ich bin überzeugt dass iris ganze
händler im bundesrat mausklicks ist das
wiedergewählt worden ist gerade direkt
von der ubs von personen tätig machen
händler geht kandidat gestellt mitte
märz um nachher wochen bewerten tag
vorhanden zum zur kriminelle sachen
gemacht hätten ist nicht wählen
die hand geküsst dass unsere bundesrätin
der sehr gute arbeit geleistet hat und
dass das sicher honoriert würde und
entsprechend ist er genau im ersten
wahlgang ich sie quält war der
bundespräsident in klarer und das hat
also die bündner delegation wurde ein
berg sich natürlich sehr kalt
er will ihn widmer schlumpf hat kurz
zuvor das finanzdepartement übernommen
als nachfolgerin des zurückgetretenen
hans rudolf merz das finanzgericht es
war mehr im amt in der reserve druck
geworden
außer der diese aufforderung die
unternehmensbesteuerung das soll ich
dann frage ich sie gar nicht als wir
über die abgeltungssteuer diskutiert
habe damit wir diese nicht überall
übereinstimmenden hausführungen auch
ausprobieren können
der deutsche finanzminister wolfgang
schäuble ist ein häufiger
ansprechpartner
sie ist eben nach einem hoch
intelligente frau und sie hat eine
persönliche art wir sind also wirklich
sehr gut ausgekommen sind müssen sie
auch noch fußball verändern ich glaube
eher schlagbar auf bundesebene ist es
wirklich ein glücksfall dass sie das
finanzdepartement wechselt hat sie hat
ziemlich nach hause was alles für euch
zu machen dass er seinerseits zu machen
und ich habe sie immer auch bei den
jahrestagungen des iwf haben wir uns
getroffen und ich weiß auch dass die
kollegen sehr geschätzt haben gerade
weil sie zurückhaltend war weil sie ein
ganz großes maß an kompetenz hatte sie
war respektiert und sie hatte zugleich
so eine sehr sympathische art kompetent
zu sein ohne überheblich oder so
aufzutreten und das hat bei vielen
großen respekt gefunden
in rekordtempo die vorlage zu billig zu
viel durch es geht darum dass sich
rettungsaktionen wie im fall ubs nicht
mehr wiederholen
der gesetzte damen und herren der
bundesrat hat sich heute über die
botschaft zur stärkung der stabilität im
finanzsektor unterhalten
die 300 tbtf too big to fail
wir haben diese in den letzten zwei
jahren dass es erhebliche risiken gibt
für die finanzstabilität in unserem land
nach dem ständerat im juni hatte der
nationalrat heute beschlossen dass die
grossbanken gemessen an ihren
risikogewichteten aktiven über
mindestens 19 prozent eigenkapital
verfügen müssen
im nationalrat stellt einzig die svp die
too big to fail vorlage grundsätzlich in
frage
die fraktion betrachtet die schärferen
eigenmittelvorschriften als
wettbewerbsnachteil für die grossbanken
zu einer großen finanzkrise gekommen im
jahr 2008 das wissen sie 2007/2008 die
hat schließlich in der folge dann auch
zu einer staatsschuldenkrise geführt und
was das ganze tragische daran ist es ist
auch so eine vertrauenskrise gekommen
vertrauenskrise in finanzmärkte
vertrauenskrise in die wirtschaft aber
detail lösung wo denn der boom gesorgt
braucht hat die heimwehr abgelehnt will
die hat das problem nicht löst bei ge
mit einer fraktur und jetzt ja aber das
als konkurrenz nach der csd ist
verpixelt dass andere teleschau das
fahrwerk position zu sein oder der
mitteparteien mit dem klo kamera
bretleben gesetzt weil tweed also ich
glaube dass ich noch sehr viel und oft
war sie beim us-modell johanna fiel der
unterschied sie schließlich erstickt
verkauft und damit eine vorreiterrolle
hat
ich glaube an sie alle hatten bundesrat
und nationalbank und finma und als
hervorragenden job gemacht
das versicherungsvertragsgesetz das ist
klassischer klassische eveline widmer
schlumpf als sie bis ins detail
reglementiert die vorlage ist zu
kompliziert und an vielen stellen kaum
verständlich die vorlage ist über haben
selbst ihre parteimitglieder sind
skeptisch einige bedenken in bezug auf
die revision haben wie von der bdp aber
auch dass es ganz tief in ihre dossiers
normalerweise bundes so das macht dass
er keiner sitzt der vorteil klassischen
dossier hat sie auf der andere täter ist
natürlich interner kritisiert wurde mit
dem mit einem detail wisse zum teil aus
fbh reserviert sie hat auch in sachen
können sie nicht hat brenntag mit am
tisch muss kann man ein positives trug
ich meine man kann eigentlich nur gut
verhandler und politisiere
munitionsdepots also im wissen worüber
man eigentlich recht also das heißt
detailtreue schavan das natürlich gerade
für das braucht man nicht immer einfach
ist will man dann eigentlich auf
griechen höherem uhr steht ein trainer
musterschülerin überhaupt auf die stoße
kenntnis als er parlamentarischer tosic
kenntnis habe ich doch sehr wichtige
felix eigenschaft kenntnis welche will
andré eigenschaften für dich und csc
kein wenn er beamte ihn und der herzig
welle bis auf der burg starb und
umsetzen
mai natürlich reiten fraktion
parlamentarier faktors die sie
durchmacht vor allem da sich auf regen
regen flüsse derzeit handel immer
zeitlos zu recht als
selbstverständlichkeit aber wenn du
warten drei geschafft gelockert im
parlament stößt ihre detailversessenheit
auf kritik die mehrheit beantragt das
neue gesetz abzulehnen
ja bedeutet antrag der mehrheit nein
bedeutet antrag der minderheit zwei
leutenegger oberholzer
sie sind der mehrheit gefolgt mit 130 zu
55 stimmen bei 5 enthaltungen
im moment ist sie allerdings haben wir
danach zusammen auf der kommission
wieder sehr kranken mannes gegangen ist
hat sich seit kurzem hat der weiß wo es
jetzt nur übrig bleibt und hat daraus
mit in kombination detailtreue
sachpolitik hat sehr viel gemacht nun
muss attraktiver
lex usa der größte schmerz ist der
verbrennungsmotor wird die
kantonalbanken könnte für den amerikaner
in konkurs darüber wer hier den banken
beziehungsweise zwölf bank noch 2 sind
bereits wieder ja wie soll ich sagen
bewältigt oder erledigt wird zwölf
banken sind in strafuntersuchungen mit
einer anklage drohung des biotech die
drohung ist noch nicht vollzogen
es besteht die gefahr einer strafanklage
und wissen wieso eigentlich
zusammenfassen einsetzt kann es mache
das gesetz und immer von dem sitz
münchen bank gegenüber usa höfner und es
muss keine einzige bank media geländer
bis bald macht das rund 80 87 dem ist es
so dass man sie und für alle machen wenn
sie wieder fallen was machen wir
eigentlich auf druck eines fremden
staates machen wir einen dringlichen
bundesbeschluss die mehrheit beantragt
ihnen nicht einzutreten
wir stimmen ab über das eintreten sie
sind der mehrheit gefolgt mit 126 zu 67
stimmen ja sich ich will jetzt nicht die
wahrheit sagen wir ich sagen würde ich
würde mich freuen darüber bereiche sage
ihnen klar ich kann damit leben es ist
ein politischer entscheid sieht man ja
morgens los gegangen weshalb man im film
bis mittag an simon zahner zählt wie
viel sie persönlich in der bank hatten
die bauern karibik investierten eigenen
rita letzter tag gemeldet mich in c40
die nächste zum jenem 1 ist eine risiko
sie eine immer quanta vergangene krone
und jetzt eine gesamtstrategie für die
kantonalbanken unterlage leiter wie ich
wünsche ihnen christa szenario ich denke
es ist wichtig dass man merkt dass man
die kontech kann hat es mit den
amerikanern ruf zeigt was überhaupt nur
möglich im rahmen von dem was der
bundesrat machen kann wird sie im
nachhinein
ich sage die treue oder durchgesprochen
sich von ihm übrig bleiben
es ist jetzt realisiert siehe da nötig
passiert nach der ablehnung von gesetzen
gegenteil erreicht sie macht weiter mit
einem neuen modell die tagesschau meine
damen und herren
guten abend jetzt ist es besiegelt das
steuerabkommen zwischen der schweiz und
deutschland für die schweiz reist er am
nachmittag finanzministerin eveline
widmer schlumpf nach berlin und das
abkommen zu unterzeichnen
vor zwei stunden im deutschen
finanzministerium finanzministerin
eveline widmer schlumpf und ihr
deutscher amtskollege wolfgang schäuble
unterzeichnen das abkommen das einen
dicken strich unter den jahrelangen
steuerstreit zwischen den beiden
nachbarn ziehen soll
nachdem wir in deutschland unter meinem
vorgänger ein solches abgeltungssteuer
modell eingeführt hatten
lag's ja nahe dass zu nutzen um daraus
einen weg zu finden um diese ewigen
schwierigkeiten im bilateralen
verhältnis zu beseitigen
wirklich nützlich oder die verbindung
von ihren kollegen im finanzminister
schäuble hat man jedoch dass rund gut
aber dass der natürliche position wo
dominiert hat im deutschen bundestag hat
das hat man muss ich ihnen aber absolut
alles versucht hat ich glaube das hat
einfach zeigt also gut die ideen sind
spart die dame ist aber sicher für die
folgen für die abkommen im stande ist
eine korrektur ist einzig richtigen auf
dem bankgeheimnis auch die abkommen acta
setze international ich mir eigentlich
auch egal dass wir vor 50 jahren standen
sich am zweiten organisiert schweiz eine
eigene lösung
aber sie hat diesen charakter und viel
kampf seit wenigen minuten erst ist es
offiziell bestätigt deutschland sagt
definitiv nein zum steuerabkommen mit
der schweiz
vorweihnachtlich friedlich die stimmung
vor dem deutschen bundesrat ganz anders
drinnen von den vermittlungsausschuss
das steuerabkommen mit der schweiz
definitiv beerdigt
wenige tage nach dem scheitern
eveline widmer schlumpf denkt laut über
den automatischen informationsaustausch
aa nach also der automatische
informationsaustausch aus an die vom
bankgeheimnis mit dem automatischen
informationsaustausch liefert schweiz
automatisch dass der name schon seit
bank da der bankkundendaten vor
ausländer an ihre herkunftsländer
transparente bahn grund also dass ich
sagen die vom bankgeheimnis und für die
zukunft stellen sich verschiedene
staaten vor der sie den automatischen
informationsaustausch oder irgendeine
form eines informationsaustausches
möchten
ob dann automatisch oder in welcher form
informationsaustausch dass ich zu
diskutieren das ist ihre haltung und
damit sind wir natürlich auch gehalten
uns überlegungen zu machen wie könnte
man unserem anspruch oder wie kann man
unserem anspruch die vergangenheit
rechtlich korrekt im rahmen des
geltenden rechts lösen gerecht werden
und gleichzeitig auch den dem anspruch
genügen dass informationen ausgetauscht
werden die künftig für ihn denn dass
steuerbetrug starken beziehung zu lasten
der herkunftsstaaten stattfinden
das ist eine diskussion die gebühren und
die müssen wir viel und dieses der
schweizer bevölkerung als
verantwortliches regierungsmitglied zu
sagen war aus meiner sicht ein
musterbeispiel für die verantwortung von
politikern zu führen und zustimmung zu
etwas zu gewinnen und zu organisieren
was so ohne weiteres von vornherein
nicht gegeben ist so viel mut braucht
man in der politischen
führungsverantwortung und den hat sie
bewiesen und sie war so erfolgreich
er will ihnen widmer schlumpf ist also
unter gewissen bedingungen bereit auf
die diskussion über den
informationsaustausch mit der eu ein
zustand die empörung darüber ist
zumindest bei den bürgerlichen groß das
kann man nicht so machen wenn das sich
das staatssekretariat eine richtung
einschlägt jene des bundesrates und frau
widmer schlumpf eine andere richtung
einschlägt dann haben wir ein gröberes
problem vor allem gegenüber
ausländischen partner hat die
finanzministerien mit diesen äußerungen
allenfalls außenpolitisch einen
flurschaden angerichtet
auszuschließen ist es sicher nicht auch
wenn die äußerungen der
bundespräsidentin durchaus
interpretationsfähig sind sie
widersprechen im kern natürlich schon
der offiziellen haltung der schweiz und
die lautet nach wie vor gegenüber den
eu-staaten
wir bieten euch die abgeltungssteuer im
gegenzug verzichtete er auf
informationen über bankkonten in der
schweiz
der freisinnige parlamentarier ruedi
noser fordert damals in einem
zeitungsinterview gar ihr müsst ihr das
steuerdossier entzogen werden
man muss zur eigenen wohnung für sich
die zitate emotionen zum problem lösen
kann erklären ich würde das nicht als
pech bezeichnet von mir aber ich bin
auch zur sprache kommen
wir haben das dann auch wieder einige
mitgenommen
und dann geht es schlag auf schlag
bundesrat hat heute entschieden bei
dieser diskussion die läuft auf ihr
dabei sind oder nicht dabei sein zu
wollen wo man auch unsere anliegen
einzubringen ein rein war das heute ein
kleiner historischer schritt der
bundesrat es erstmals bereit mit dem
ausland über den automatischen
informationsaustausch zu sprechen
die unbeliebtesten aller beamten von
ganz europa haben sich heute in bern
getroffen es sind die steuer kommissare
die steuerkommission blicken alle in die
gleiche richtung
ihr ziel ist es steueroasen
trockenzulegen
dazu tauschen sie sich mit ihren
kollegen aus ganz europa aus vor allem
über den automatischen
informationsaustausch die steuer
kommentare der eu länder setzen auf
diese informationen
deshalb sei es wichtig dass die
steuerverwaltungen aller länder daran
teilnehmen er will ihn widmer schlumpf
wird zwar als gast auf dem obligaten
gruppenbild er an den rand gedrängt die
schweizer anliegen versucht sie aber ins
zentrum zu rücken auch beim zweiten
thema des treffens der
unternehmensbesteuerung wenn man jetzt
wirklich ein stück weiter gekommen vor
allem im bereich der diskussion über den
automatischen informationsaustausch über
das projekt die man das ausgleichen was
von uns aus gesehen die eckwerte sein
müssen wir einmal täuschen die bilder
nicht das gesprächsklima zwischen der
schweiz und frankreich im steuerstreit
hat sich deutlich verbessert
so unterzeichneten beide seiten ein
abkommen dass frankreich bei der
fahndung nach steuerflüchtlingen
sogenannte gruppenanfragen erlaubt im
september 2015 akzeptiert der
nationalrat den automatischen
informationsaustausch nicht die frage es
ist nur die frage wie man sich hier
positioniert und für die schweizer
wirtschaft die bestmöglichste
ausgangsposition zu haben
zum glück haben wir in den letzten
jahren die notwendigen schritte gemacht
oder mal so informationsaustausch war ja
lange zeit fällt die schweiz ein no go
das muss man einfach noch wissen und
dann kam eine
überholende entwicklung die ein bisschen
mit den vereinigten staaten von amerika
zu tun hat in den letzten jahren
plötzlich hat sich die lage unheimlich
verändert
die internationale gemeinschaft hat sich
entschieden gemäss oecd-standard
gegenseitig automatische bankdaten zu
liefern damit die staaten die
steuerehrlichkeit ihre bürger prüfen
können
es ist klar dass dies für eine
freisinnige partei schwierige konzepte
sind sie wirklich gibt es nicht mal
mailand als auch mit der an zwei dingen
auch das einzige land wo ich kam an und
für sich noch us-daten für sich bald ich
amerika oder andere amt wäre
datenaustausch und ich bin sicher auto
mit kran werden später mehr mitziehen
mitmachen
aber die herren immer würden als erste
machen bisher befindet da segelt luke
durch diese mit mach mit wir sehen
natürlich das ist der stand als mehr
freiheit paris kennt das ja sie dass es
situationen die kommune landesrat falb
glaube denn nicht nur dort erste team
war der liebste und kinderzimmer getötet
zu haben der verordnung des erhöht sich
die finanzen mit dem heute hobbys ruft
mich nach amerika immer noch im krieg
wäre mit dann aber anders
zwar bedeutet es doch nicht mit eveline
widmer-schlumpfs erfolgen sondern mit
einer bienen kampagne steigt die bdp in
den wahlkampf 2015
es ist der originell sie ich glaube
nicht dass die bilder kampagne großen
volksfest und das leben ja mal ein
resultat
[Applaus]
das jahr 2010 ist
sehr passend auch wieder wir alles um
könig es braucht so dass peter wohl
clippers bradley sind überflüssig
die folge für bdp parteipräsident martin
landolt
ein bitterer verlust von stimmen am
sonntag im oktober 2015
ich bin sicher zu bieten was das er soll
dort meine partei betrifft in bezug auf
die prognosen die behaupten und auf die
tatsache dass wir jetzt den tod
geschrieben wurden wir leben noch
lange gesichter auch bei der bdp im chor
punkte die svp erreicht 28 prozent plus
1,4 prozentpunkte es ist nach 2007 das
zweitbeste ergebnis der applaus fiel
traumatologie locker
[Applaus]
sieber geht bei der svp als links
deshalb die helme svp hat jetzt mit der
pc-sparte krakow für lokal und für 12
oder eveline widmer schlumpf
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich habe die entscheidung getroffen
offiziell am letzten montag am montag
nach den wahlen weil ich auch dass das
offenhalten sollte der partei den rücken
freihalten wollte für die hallen
die parteileitung war informiert dass
ich mir diese gedanken mache voraus aber
danke ich ihn frau bundesräten für all
das was sie in acht jahren im bundesrat
für unser land geleistet haben
ich starte in für ihre große arbeit und
ihren unermüdlichen einsatz und ich
danke ihnen für jede leidenschaft für
die lösung von problemen und für den
respekt in der politik herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und ich glaube durch die
wiederherstellung von status quo an bei
uns monika hand vor acht jahren haben
sich jetzt maut hof der hoffnung dass es
jetzt wieder ruhiger wird und dass man
das kapital für mehrere pläne die drei
stärksten partei handys 2 und der
einstieg wird eine und wenn man nur gast
im bundesrat einbringen
also ran natürlich reicht der bundesrat
sei tabu der freisinnige polizei dem
fertig mit der mitte links regierung aus
dem wald die steine als gott alles was
ich habe mindestens eine freue ich mich
schon einmal stimmen oder sie seitlich
kandidieren im hartz iv diskussion freak
macht dass man es wieder ein
pragmatischer weg suchen grundstück
lieferung die zukunft
hätte sich zur wiederwahl stellt das
heißt nicht dass man sie auch gewählt
die ganze hektik wird sie abgewählt wird
sie nicht abgewählt
die wäre so stark wohl das heißt sie
steht schweiz wieder geknallt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich stelle mir die frage nie in meinem
leben ob es sich gelohnt hat oder nicht
es ist einfach wie ihr sitzt und ich
denke das ist auch das was mir eine
gewisse gelassenheit gegeben hat in all
diesen jahren also ich habe mich nie
gefragt würde ich etwas noch einmal
machen völlig nutzlose frage sie können
nie etwas noch einmal eng es müssen
einfach vorwärts gehen und es ist im
moment dass sie entscheidend ist es
richtig und dann ist es auch am schluss
richtig gemacht einen sehen und ich
denke ja ich habe meine arbeit gemacht
ich habe sie meine ich nicht so ganz
schlecht gemacht
wir haben verschiedene resultat
erreichen können und damit ist mein
auftrag in anführungszeichen
[Musik]
doch mit dem neuen toyota rav4 firma 4
und hybrid die ideale kombination für
die schweiz